mais d'abord le photovoltaïque gagne du
terrain en indre et loire
objectif 30 % d'énergie renouvelable
d'ici dix ans tu au delà des projets
médiatiques comme ce parc de 100 ha
promis par la mairie de tours d'autres
installations doivent voir le jour
c'est le cas à drap chez et aux joueurs
en touraine m mais si l'un est
facilement acceptées par la population
l'autre non explications avec romain des
villes un peu plus de 4 hectares le long
de la ligne à grande vitesse vers
bordeaux en bordure de la rd 59
d'anciennes terres agricoles considéré
comme dégradées suite aux travaux de la
lgv drache et devrait bientôt accueillir
7000 700 panneaux photovoltaïques
l' enquête publique a été ouverte il ya
une semaine pour sa première permanence
en mairie
le commissaire enquêteur ne fait
aucunement face à une levée de boucliers
personne n'est venu ce matin dans trois
semaines
il commencera la rédaction de son
rapport après avoir recueilli les
remarques des citoyens c'est vraiment
une façon de valoriser une zone qui
était qui était resté à l'abandon donc
ça représente quand même resté assez
positive pour m c'est que le sud du
département prend goût aux champs
photovoltaïques plus de 21000 panneaux
installés à descartes
vingt mille prévus à prouilly sur claise
des projets and what he paulmy bosser et
donc d'arracher la communauté de
communes loches au sud touraine
réfléchit à en implanter sur l'ancienne
déchetterie
son président est un opposant aux
éoliennes sur le territoire pour les
panneaux photovoltaïques
l'idée c'est que leurs vues ne nuisent
pas à l'environnement
une condition c'est l'insertion
paysagère et puis savoir sur quelle
terre on l'aimait quand je parle des
projets que la communauté de communes
porte c'est par exemple sur d'anciens
dépôts d'ordures la salle donnant par
exemple bosser sur claise également ce
sont des sites qui sont grands qui sont
pour l'instant inutilisable puisque ces
casiers sont plein changement de cap
direction le nord du département où des
habitants s'inquiètent d'un projet de
plus de 160 hectares
une centaine d'hectares se situe en
plein champ à distance des habitations
mais une partie du champ agrivolt ax6
entre deux hameaux c'est là où le bât
blesse pour ces riverains futurs projets
qui représentent autour des habitations
à peu près une soixantaine d'hectares va
couper complètement savez une pollution
visuelle complète puisque ça fait les
panneaux font de m 82 une fois posée
donc on aura un bandeau autour des
maisons de deux mètres 82e et les
riverains veulent se faire entendre
avant l' enquête publique
une réunion entre habitants communauté
de communes et promoteur du projet est
prévue cette semaine